obviously either one of your parents you
couldn't really go to and talk about
really bad things that happened did you
feel like
there's no real adult in charge here
yeah i think you know i'm an only child
and um there was just this kind of sense
of like
me being an adult from day one they kind
of always would take me to dinners with
their friends and
i would sit at the table and i learned
how to converse like an adult i mean i
think actually in many ways is
was good for me um
but also
yeah definitely
um i didn't have a feeling of like
parent child in a lot of ways it's a
weird thing you just grow up really fast
and then on top of it once i was 12 13
kind of people at least i need me now i
look at pictures of myself and i'm like
it's crazy that anyone ever thought i
was an adult i look like such a child
that being said i did look older um and
so the world kind of accepted me as
looking like a full-grown woman people
would look at you and they'd sexualize
you at the age of 12 and 13. yes yeah
it's funny i'm laughing because um
the new york post had some headline that
was like sad and sexualized childhood
which just like really cracked me up i
was like oh maybe that should be my
[ __ ] stamp just sad and sexualized
that's the takeaway from the book jesus
christ lord help me well just some of
the things that happened to you were sad
as a result i mean uh even your mom
walking around with you and saying hey
that guy's looking at you look at that
you know you do become self-conscious i
imagine like oh jesus christ am i
creating a scene here what am i what am
i doing you know again i think my mom is
sort of saying like look you can
celebrate that boys look at you that's
nice you know it's still you know
whatever in her mind um but definitely
it made me super aware of myself but by
the way i think all you know this is
something that a lot of people talk
about is how aware of themselves women
are that they even when they're kind of
alone and you know getting dressed or
just by themselves they're kind of aware
of what they might look like um because
we do learn that you know that that's
the way to to get love to to be powerful
to be successful so you become
really good at kind of no assessing
yourself um and then on top of it if it
becomes your means to you know financial
success which modeling that's you know
what your job is is to know when and how
you look good
you really become super self-aware
you